ly populated areas in the world we can
see it frankly just by looking at the
backdrop behind you also the Hamas
forces are believed to have brought
multiple Israeli captives back into Gaza
do you know anything about that what can
you report at this
stage all right yumna please take cover
if you are in a position to do so safely
you can explain to us what we're
happening if you are not in a position
to do so safely then please get to
safety no it's okay
um this is a mile attack on on Palestine
Tower right in the middle of Gaza
City Y take a moment to breathe take a
moment you and your team take a moment
to breathe okay just take a moment as we
are looking at this um picture we are
ours into this war between Gaza and
Israel and we have just witnessed live
what an Israeli air raid looks like on a
populated area of Gaza City uh what we
believe is a residential building what
you're looking at right now is a life
shot of Gaza City and after Hamas
launched an
attack uh in and around the Israeli Terr
around the Gaza Strip while Israel
retaliated by bombarding multiple
Targets in Gaza um for those of you
who've been watching us the last few
minutes uh we're all a little bit shaken
by what we've just seen which was an air
raid on a
building just behind our correspondent
yumna aside as she was reporting now
we're getting our team to safety and we
are going to turn now to nid Ibrahim
who's in rala in the occupied West Bank
frankly we're all still a little bit
shaken